[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record
we talk about whatever we want [ __ ] ass
aj hey what's up what's up what's up
what's aj standport
um yes andrew joseph
you got one of them right joseph yep uh
uh this one's so random i wanted to say
absolutely
accurate abigail yeah that's for sure
why does every filipino arthur
yeah okay you knew that i think we do
know that you're our friend
arthur joseph i guess but i got it right
wow joe
i thought you didn't know that no oh
they knew this
why does every filipino family have an
rj or an aj because they have two first
names jr for sure they are because they
have two first names
there's always a j in there yeah and
then they shorten it can we come to one
of your parties yes
so [ __ ] fun all you guys do is sing
usually we would um so my mom's house
in riverside there's too much corona
going on i lived there for 29 years
um every like kind of big occasion we'd
have everyone just come through and
riverside's far for some people but i
try to make it like is it that
big ass house that we went to party at
like ages ago yes that house is massive
yeah like high ceilings and stuff jam
sessions and yeah things like that theme
like theme um halloween we do for sure
like the costumes we had at disney last
year so everyone came into disney
universe so
how cool star wars marvel whatever i
love it and everyone's jamming at the
end of the night
i love that part are all your friends
musicians um
pretty much i'd say they all love music
for sure but i do have a lot of
musician friends that yeah we we vibe it
out for sure
jamming and stuff yeah dude i don't know
if i'm mixing up with someone i'm sorry
if i am but did you
do the prom thing yeah red roses
probably
was you yeah yeah yeah i thought you're
about to say did you do a song called
lemonade no
no the raw filipino yeah red rose is
prominent we had a live
house band and everything you're doing
the prom because i remember thinking
like oh that's so cool i didn't go to my
prom
yeah that's what i did it for for my
friends who didn't have a problem
we did two of those before it got so
tiring like you know i'm not a
corporation or anything
so it got hard like running a prom
you know but we'd have a house band and
that's what i love live music
live music just has a different energy
so different i miss it
so much right now like so much even
live recorded music like edm
just has it even this one's just going i
can't beat it
because they have control if they're
feeling a song the crowd's feeling the
song he'll just make it go longer yeah
and you see his face like this
yeah you just feel it for some reason i
don't like live recorded music
that's what all edm concerts are well no
i like live music or just
studio produced music i don't like it i
don't like it like a live video
like a live stream i don't like it i'd
rather just be there live so you don't
like even seeing uh steve aoki
live yeah about live recordings of it
yes and then recording
of the live stream
so you hear like the reverb or the
ambient noise of the con
are you just saying that you like being
there thank you yes
thank you i didn't think it was that
cool some live recordings though are
dope because
so it can't be captured again yeah it's
true and interactions with the
audience and things like that i would do
without the audience but it's
it's really about the playing i it
doesn't matter yeah the ambiance is fine
i think that the magic you you follow
the flow of it and that's what i like
about it
how do you feel about all those uh
online live performances now then
because that's a huge
it's cool that there's a pivot but i'm
just like i haven't been watching
really any of them at all there's so
many cool bands now that are like
pivoting to that they're like okay since
we can't go on tour we're gonna have our
own virtual tour yeah
that's cool but it ain't my tv oh dude
[ __ ]
you know what's crazy is i follow scary
pockets right they're really cool so
sick so do i this guy pops out of
nowhere
and sings and i'm like oh [ __ ] it's sick
they're a funk cover band yeah funk so
they take whatever pop music and then
they
funk cover it okay they do function
although the the cover that we did was
not
technically a funk groove it was more
like a shuffle but it was like
it still was different from the yeah
they kind of do disco jazz all kinds of
stuff but yeah yeah
it was cool to be on there i was honored
you know i think that
they might have called me in because um
don't hit the asian market maybe the
asian market
but you know they probably thought it
was like a name but then i told them i
was like yeah i went to berkeley
um berkeley college music in boston and
they're like well i didn't know you were
like a musician
like oh you must have not watched my
videos or it was so weird wait
what because i had asked if i could play
keys
in my collab and they were like uh we
usually don't have anyone play but i've
seen it
you know i've seen them see have people
play their instruments yeah
they didn't they didn't do enough
research to know that you're right and
you know hey i'll i'll respect to
to ryan and jack and everybody but um i
feel like they didn't know
that i was i was really trying to jam
with them
you know what i mean like beyond their
level but it was cool to be a singer for
once
i will say that like i usually hide
behind
my piano and my guitar because i don't
know what to do with my hands
when i'm singing oh so you'll watch that
you don't do this
i think i'm like putting my hands in
like aren't you supposed to cover one
ear and then like visualize noise
how is that what they're doing
[Laughter]
everyone does that [ __ ] that's the
christina aguilera thing you know
i got to do that for once
[Music]
every [ __ ] person but yeah it was
very very cool to be on that channel
and be a just a singer you know because
i also
i don't consider myself a singer like i
you know i'm hanging around with tori
kelly jeremy
like these guys who have insane vocals
yeah but you're a singer because you
seemed
in your er thank you thank you joe
i appreciate it nice so collabs
are still a thing then or was it like
virtual or no that was real
and that was like two years ago oh that
was pre-covered yeah recovered
but i have i was like um speaking of the
online shows and stuff i've been putting
together um
some shows there's a show i started
called crazy talented asians i know kind
of corny
but it it is cool that because i brought
it to the musical theater space
so you know in those shows they're
called cabarets where you have everyone
sing a solo i thought that was for
strippers yeah i was like god that's
what cabarets are
i mean you can probably attribute it to
that space as well oh
but a cabaret in a musical theater sense
is like everyone's singing a solo from
show or if there's a theme or whatever
usually those nights are like all white
people maybe there's like one
asian or one person of color and one
black guy why because is it lame
no because that's what the space is
dominated by just like white actors and
actresses right
so i wanted to just start a show where
everyone was asian
on there so then the audiences who
started showing up at a usually white
space
were asian and you know like filipinos
and like my aunties and stuff coming to
there's this venue in hollywood called
rockwell and it's usually like white
dinner theater usually you know um so it
was cool to start that but i started
doing it online
so starting doing the the live stream
and and editing the videos together and
stuff like that so
i would say i am like kind of tired of
this like zoom
kind of concert thing but if you do it
in a way where you're like
getting some variety or editing videos
in a different way
there's a host in between so then the
audience knows it's like
kind of live and you're interacting with
them then i i'd say
it can work but also i think we're going
to get tired of doing these probably
in the next couple months because it's
been a long time already
was kind of like like back in the day
with america's
[ __ ] what's it called next top model
funniest home videos no no the the
singer one
a lot of american things american idol i
mean that one american idol
american ninja challenge american ninja
warrior america's most wanted title i
forgot the word
that's the first big one yeah so like
back in those times you know you have to
like text your vote or whatever so it's
way more interactive with the live
audience and i think that's the reason
why
it became so popular so now we're kind
of a little bit
reverting or not reverting but yeah
going back to
you want to feel like you've you're
connecting yeah yeah
you've helped the outcome yeah exactly i
think everyone that still will live on
forever of course like
even when you're watching live streams
on twitch and stuff like you're just
saying something
or people are donating so they could say
your name you know what i mean even that
small
interaction is fulfilling to anybody i
mean i do it when i'm watching streams
too
i think it's just like kind of a
subconscious thing so when you donate
the cam girls you
uh you're like please say aj please say
aj
that's where it started though right
that's what twitch culture started i
never got it either
cam girl culture i'm sure that that's
how that culture
ended up becoming part of the game
culture like donating and stuff and
yeah well i think it first came from the
the the cam girl stuff because i was
like oh i was laughing at like how
we did a brand deal for a live stream
company and then they were giving us
donations
for like the stream and i was like this
is so funny i feel like a cam girl
right and this was before i think it was
before twitch yeah
that's probably where that culture uh
kind of came from that subculture that's
pretty much
all tech moving forward all starts from
the porn industry right yeah like pov
like or even like the the the prevalence
of like
blue rays that's because the porn
industry took that oh yeah
yeah you know how back when uh blu-rays
came out it was blu-rays or
hdd yeah yeah and then blu-rays won
because the porn industry took blu-ray
really oh i slapped them
i remember that though cause it was like
toshiba and all them doing the hd tv
and sony really was like the one yeah
pushing blu-rays forward pushing blu-ray
because i think they helped produce a
lot of that stuff
but you know when you're watching so
much content from like playing games and
all that like you don't got no
time right so that's why this video is
brought to you by postmates
postmates oh yeah you don't got no time
and you're busy online
and you're working working on your
rhymes not doing the crime
right and then you're like on your zoom
calls or whatever
and and you're just watching the show
you don't want it to be interrupted
that is the main reason why post mates
is good for you you can order
you can get like man you got to get
dinner oh no
i don't have no time but i also don't
want to go out because a covet baby
it's not safe right now so that's why i
like using postmates they deliver food
from every restaurant that i can think
of
right to my door just download the
postmate app
on ios or android to find your favorites
and get anything you want delivered
within
the hour and for a limited time our
listeners only postmates is giving you
100
of free delivery credit for your first
seven days that's one week
so start your free deliveries download
the app use the code off the record
that's called off the record for
100 of free delivery credit with no
minimum purchase for
seven days but i don't i don't like to
strategize my porn like that
i just kind of
i just go with the flow i just just let
it
let it happen let it happen oh but i
haven't been able to jack off recently
because i've been camping
and it's not that easy is it hard to
jack off when you're camping because
it's cold or
it's impolite that's a routine is it
impolite maybe sharing attention it's
like eight well i'm in a hammock too
oh dude the way we can okay so his hand
his hammock just shaking
you just hear the fabric have you guys
slept in a
stomach before like slept i did take a
nap did your back hurt
not a full night not a full night what
does it feel like it feels like your
mother is rocking you slowly
like that you zip it up
so it's like a net over right no i mean
you can get those kinds but you just
kind of
you just kind of wrap yourself around
like that if you want what if like you
know like i don't know if you sleep like
this but when i sleep
sometimes after move like get
comfortable yeah
does the when you do that there's like
the whole thing start shaking or do you
is it just so comfortable it's
form-fitting
but i mean i bet you can't just go like
if you're a stomach sleeper that doesn't
work because then you're like a banana
uh i sleep on my side or i i just
it's so comfortable that you sleep on
your back okay and i don't sleep on my
back
yeah yeah so there's a way to hook it up
like you know those sleeping pads
yeah uh that you lay out yeah use that
first
like the inflatable ones yeah yeah you
put that first and then you get a
sleeping bag
man it was like below 40 degrees it was
cold but i was warm man it felt great
yeah it was so good and i think i'm just
hooked to like hammocks now
cool like the first you're sewing up in
your bedroom yeah
let's get this mattress out of here
that's pretty cool you should do that in
your studio
i am going to no way we have we have
support beams
that can probably a real wood cause some
of them are foam no it's it's
it's it's it's exposed beam it's it's
it's in the studio
because remember you used to have in the
other house that you lived in the
the actual frame for the hammock oh
right i got it at ikea that was
i that's how i started sleeping in
helmets hammocks because when i moved
i didn't have a bed for like a month so
i had a uh
ikea hammock and i just knocked out in
that thing for like
until i bought a bed why don't you make
your inside once you make the inside of
the studio
like the outside mmm yeah that's a
pretty good idea
i think we're going to do a tropical
hawaii theme so it might
work yeah are you going to be a plant
dad
um i don't know i gave away all my
plants but i do love plants i like a
green thumb
yeah i love plants yeah well um
i went to this secret like camp spot
right and my buddy
he's super improv like he just goes with
the flow
he doesn't prep all he lives with is
just a toothbrush and like
a couple of cup of noodles and he could
be in the forest for a while but most of
us can't do that kind of [ __ ] right
he also doesn't eat very much he doesn't
eat he also looks like soy tea
a little bit yeah he does i love you
he's my brother i love him
that's why he can survive he refuses to
use a sleeping bag
what in 40 degree weather he refuses to
use
he's just in the house ain't no [ __ ]
and i'm just like a sleeping bag doesn't
make me a [ __ ] i was the most
comfortable one out
why does he he brings it he's just like
[ __ ] i'm too madly for this [ __ ]
he doesn't bring one oh yeah i wanted to
ask you about that because it looks so
nice did you guys
it was it like one of those places where
you could just drive out to and you
could just camp anywhere no how did that
work
we needed it we broke some laws we broke
some laws oh
cool good for you yeah i like that yeah
we just
went deep into the forest it was all
based off a picture
my friend said look at this picture wow
it's a
beautiful teal lake right beautiful and
no [ __ ] i i thought that it was just
edited because you know whenever there's
landscape photography and all that like
it never saturated the way that it does
in the photo
but when you get there it's legit a teal
lake it'll shock you like what the [ __ ]
how's that and there's
glaciers like in the middle of summer
man yeah so it's nice and cool and
you know it was like 100 degrees but
when you go up there
it was nice man it was like 70. so
we're going and and we're looking around
for like a place to just camp out on
and we find this cold it was kind of
like an island right
and we went pretty deep into it we we
walked six miles with like
60 pounds of equipment it was nuts and
everyone was just so down and like
you know we're like yeah i'll hold this
for you and then we'll just keep going
do you leave your car
parked there for a couple of days so
you're away from your car for a couple
of days
yeah yeah it's just a public parking
spot yeah so
but i guess it's deep enough into the
kind of camping i've been wanting to do
like not by my car camping i was not
even prepped though so
next time we're probably gonna be
prepped because he didn't explain like
yo we need this or this we just grabbed
bottles of water and we just prepared
for the worst because it was like
we know this dude and he's just he could
sleep in
on leaves he just wings it yeah but for
us we're just like all right we should
get this all right let's go we just
don't know what to expect yeah yeah but
now you know
now we know but yeah i was just like
it was crazy because it was my first
time backpacking and i didn't even plan
on backpacking wow
we brought a tent and all that stuff and
did you have a backpack then or you just
had like a
no dude we had all of us had two back
like normal backpacks like i had like a
backpack with a with that water
tube thing what do you call it camelback
i had a camelback in the front and i had
a regular
north face backpack in the back you're
wearing two backpacks like
all of us were wearing like two
backpacks with holding [ __ ] in our hands
looking up like noobs dude and people
were just like you guys got a lot of
stuff and we're like
yeah i had a bag of [ __ ] snacks and
chips we didn't prepare for food dude i
planned for this guys
how long was that trip uh friday to
sunday
well so it's not very long we survived
you know yeah but
bro it was crazy but in that chaos
though
i was really able to just appreciate a
lot of [ __ ] and realize that we don't
really
need much like for example at night we
figured out like
how to make a fire and keep it going and
then everyone was just kind of like
let's just
get some rocks together all this you
guys have a lighter or matches
luckily i have a fire starter too where
you could just go oh
yeah and then um i thought you guys
slammed two rocks together i was like
[ __ ] that's hardcore amazing we set up
hammocks where it was like
it was like a three trees and we had
three hammocks going and then there was
wind and we had to figure out
how to block the wind and we put up tarp
and it turned out to be like a half
tp thing where it kept it warm just in
our area
yeah and then that water is like
negative three it's like
ice water bro it's so cold but it's
refreshing
and we're just using that to like brush
our teeth shower everything did you did
you
go swimming in it for like a second
negative three i just
don't know we kept jumping in it but you
have to come out right away
if you don't come out right away your
your limbs start feeling like it's cold
like it's freezing yeah hypothermia or
something spiky
feeling because it's so cold yeah like
you'll feel it when you're like alright
it's time to go you know
yeah but it's [ __ ] amazing because
like that's the first thing we do
we get up we just jump in there that's
our shower you take a [ __ ] in the woods
you just
dig a hole so nice it is and there's no
one there
so yeah smell a little bit worse than
usual though it really does because it
doesn't go in the water you know when
you're pooping in the water like
immediately gets sealed but when you're
[ __ ] you're like damn this thing
kind of smells
it has to be like at least uh how much
how deep does
that hole have to be oh it's not like
they're following any laws so i don't
think it mattered
but like the natural camping you know i
just dug a hole
and then covered it up animal style yeah
animal style
animals don't even dig though so we're
already more polite
more polite than they are the way that
the force just energizes you it's
[ __ ] weird right so we'll sleep at
like
i don't know like nine or ten just
naturally because we're not on our
phones there's no reception
right so you just naturally sleep two
hours after the sunset
and then um you might wake up in the
middle of the night because you hear
some noise or whatever
and you would think that you would have
this groggy wake up but we all woke up
at like
four or five in the morning just refresh
the air and the oxygen
come in yeah it's crazy like we'll sleep
like an hour or two
and just be completely fine for the rest
of the day it was not did your friend
who
didn't like sleeping bags did they have
a blanket at least no he stayed up all
night what just watching
tending the fire oh my god yeah what
that's hardcore
he is man he's not on drugs that's crazy
he just pulls
he pulled like a two or three day
all-nighter well he slept the first
night
the first night this guy's crazy we uh
we didn't have a campsite
because we didn't plan ahead so it was
all booked up so we pulled over on the
side of the road
and we put um two of our uh suvs
together
and we both have roof racks so we just
hung hammocks in between
and so he slapped crazy yeah and a
couple of us slept outside
that does sound fun yeah like like it's
survival mode just wing it
yeah yeah and then no reception thing
that's like it's awesome
and weed helps a lot too it
[ __ ] what's going on you take a hit like
this it's all good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you